Well, good morning again, church, it's great to see you.
If you are new to our church,
we're so thankful you'd be here.
We would hope that you feel encouraged
and welcomed, yet challenged in your pursuit of Jesus.
We'd love to have you introduce yourself
to us out at the new here area in the lobby right
after we're done, just so we can get to know you,
ask questions of us, all of that.
We'd love to answer those if we can.
And if you call Henderson Hills home,
it's always great to be together.
Uh, we are so thankful to be able
to walk this journey together towards Jesus.
It is a gift to our souls.
Uh, as we continue our series
through the book of First Samuel.
I wanna share again, a, a well-known illustration.
I've shared this probably two or three times in the last six
or seven years I've been here,
but I feel like it applies well again today.
Uh, so imagine I tell my son to go clean his room.
Now, uh, by the way, that's not a picture of one
of our boys' rooms, just that's a random picture off the
internet, so don't be accusing them of anything.
Uh, but just, you know, I say go clean your room.
It's clear. He knows what I mean. Right?
Well, imagine he comes back a couple hours later
and he proudly says, Hey dad,
I memorized what you said.
You said go clean your room.
Like, what? How's, how am I gonna respond to that?
Like, oh, congratulations son.
That's exactly what I wanted you to do, right?
Here's the donut. No, like, how would I respond?
No, go clean your room, man.
So he comes back a couple hours later, said, Hey dad,
listen, uh, I can say go clean your room in Greek.
What? No, go clean your room, man. Like, what?
What are you doing? Okay.
Comes back a couple hours later, he says, okay, dad, listen,
I've been really taking to heart what you said.
And, uh, here's what we're gonna do.
Me and a couple friends we're gonna gather every week
and we're going to talk about
what it would look like if I cleaned my room
and we're gonna write songs about it
and sing about cleaning your room.
And we're gonna just sit there
and really just, just abide in that statement.
Go clean your room. Like, no, that's not gonna work. Right?
He knows the, the call was to go clean his room.
Like it's, it's abundantly clear
and not just clean it partially like he knows
to clean the room fully and immediately.
Well, something similar actually is
what is the final nail in the coffin
of King Saul's leadership in one Samuel.
Remember, one of the keys to a monarchy working at all
in Israel was the king's obedience to the Lord's commands.
So our passage today will show us
what happened when Saul didn't obey,
but it will also serve as a warning to us today
who call ourselves followers of Jesus.
It will, it will caution us to how we handle similar things.
So if you're not already there, go ahead
and take your copy of God's Word
and turn with me to one Samuel, chapter 15,
one Samuel 15.
Look at the whole chapter today.
What we've seen so far in the entire book of one Samuel
as we walk this journey is that Saul has shown glimpses
of what could make him a great king if he
really wanted to be one.
But the prevailing trend in Saul's life has been toward
failure, set up that way.
And then the whole time we've seen very little else.
But God is gracious. Look here at verses one through three.
'cause it seems like God is giving Saul one more chance
to show that he could be the king.
And it's against an enemy
that the Israelites have had since they left
Egypt in the Exodus.
This group of people will see in this section have been a,
just a thorn in the side of Israel,
completely opposed to God.
So God says to Saul, Hey, here's another chance,
chapter 15 verse one.
Samuel said to Saul,
Samuel was God's prophet speaking on behalf of God.
Samuel said to Saul, the Lord sent me
to anoint you king over his people, Israel.
Now therefore, listen, you'll hear a word like that a lot.
Listen to the words of the Lord,
thus says the Lord of hosts.
I have noted what Amalek did
to Israel in opposing them on the way when
they came up out of Egypt.
Now, go Saul and strike Amalek
and devote them to destruction all that they have.
Do not spare them, but kill both man and woman, child
and infant, ox and sheep, camel and donkey.
Now, before we go any further here, we need to deal
with this difficult idea
that God would command the utter destruction of a people
because it feels kinda like some sort of ethnic cleansing,
weird, sad thing.
And listen, there's no, there's no easy answer to this
that doesn't sound cold.
It's caused people to question their faith.
But here's what we do know about this.
It is God's judgment on sin.
Like I said, these people were completely opposed to God
and to his people in every way, very destructive.
This was God's judgment on sin.
Wrath is always God's judgment on sin,
both in the Old Testament and in the New Testament.
Even the New Testament kind
of focuses it toward the end times more eschatological idea
of judgment at the end.
But don't forget, even in the New Testament,
there are scenes like Anani
and Sfi in Acts five,
where God's judgment happens immediately in the moment.
And so God's wrath is always judgment on sin.
But I I we need to consider this.
'cause even in Saul's day, this practice
of wiping out nations was becoming less common,
primarily because it's it's singular purpose.
The only reason God commanded it was clearing the land
for God's people, which also
means that there's no warrant for it today
because it was tied to God's covenant with his people
at that time and for that purpose.
And so there's no reason for it to happen.
And again, it was then, it was very strategic in that way.
But the the point though, again, no easy answers,
but the point is that the thread throughout the Bible is
that sin will be judged like that's abundantly clear.
That's what we learn here. That's why this happens.
That's why we see Anani survive.
All sin will be judged,
whether that's immediately or in the future.
God is just, sin will be judged.
In fact, what we're seeing from this scene is
that this is a, a foreshadowing of what could even happen
to Saul if he chooses not to follow the Lord.
And so look now what happened next?
That was the command verses four through nine.
Show us really the battle.
This is really the only section of the entire chapter
that deals with the battle.
The focus is on Samuel confronting Saul.
We'll see that, but look at verses four through nine.
So Saul summoned the people
and numbered them in Teim, 200,000 men on foot,
10,000 men of Judah.
Saul came to the city of Amalek and lay wait in the valley.
And Saul said to the kin Knights, this was a, a group
of people that helped the Israelites.
Even though they lived with Amalek,
they helped the Israelites in that journey.
Saul said to them, go depart, go down from
among the malachite, lest I destroy you with them.
For you showed kindness to all the people of Israel.
When they came up out of Egypt, he warned the, the ones
who might be friendly to them.
So the Ken Knights departed from among the malachite
and Saul defeated the Amalekites from Hala as far as shore,
which is east of Egypt.
And he took a gag, the king of the Amalekites, alive
and devoted to destruction all the people
with the edge of the sword.
But Saul and the people spared a gag
and the best of the sheep
and of the oxen, of the fatted calves and the lambs
and all that was good and would not utterly destroy them.
All that was despised and worthless.
They did devote to destruction.
Now, it's interesting the way the narrator
framed this because it's very clear
the contrast between what God had commanded Saul to do
and and what he actually did, right?
So remember verse three, go and strike a mal
and devote to destruction all that they have.
Do not spare anything.
People or animal don't spare anything.
But what do we see Saul
and his men do in verses four through nine?
Like, do you see the difference here?
There's no doubt what happened here.
Saul did not obey God's command.
Well, look at how God responds. Verses 10 and 11.
The word of the Lord came to Samuel.
I regret that I've made Saul King
for he has not turned back from following me
and has not performed my commandments.
And Samuel was angry and he cried to the Lord all night.
Now, we'll come back to the re
regret thing a little bit later.
But, but did you see Samuel's heart here, this prophet
of the Lord who God used to anoint, who's used to lead, like
what a powerful picture of his heart devoted to God.
He is torn up by the fact that Saul did what he did,
that Saul was not the one that God had originally chosen.
Like He, he was wrestling with this reality
that things are going south real fast.
Like our prayer should be God, make us
that committed to your standards, to your holiness, to you
and, and your glory, God, make us that committed,
that we are torn up even when somebody else sins
because it taints the glory of God.
And so what does Samuel need to do?
Well, he needed to find Saul and confront him. Of course.
So look at verse 13.
Samuel came to Saul
and Saul said to him, blessed be you to the Lord.
I have performed the commandment of the Lord.
Now, did you catch how Saul responded to Samuel?
Samuel shows up and Saul walks
out a little bit of buttering up.
Hey, Samuel, man, hey, you're a,
you are such a blessing to the Lord.
You know that like you're just so great. Love you Samuel.
You're such a great guy.
But then he preemptively tries to cover, watch this.
Hey Samuel, you're a great guy. I obeyed the Lord.
Aren't aren't you proud of me, Samuel?
I obeyed what God commanded me to do. I I aren't you proud?
Now, the only thing Samuel knows at this point is
what God had told him.
Samuel wasn't at the battle. He didn't know how it all went.
That's all he knows. He's walking up to Saul.
All he knows is God said, Saul didn't obey.
And Saul comes to him and says, no, I did.
Which is what makes the next scene so tragically humorous.
'cause Saul had just said, Hey, Samuel, I obeyed.
But now look at verse 14.
And Samuel said, what then is this bleeding
or the sound that a sheep makes?
What then is this bleeding of the sheep in my ears
and the lowing of the oxen that I hear?
Like Samuel shows up, he's like, wait a sec, salt.
If if you obey, then why am I hearing all these animals?
If you did obey, if God told you to destroy everything,
why do I still hear all of the animals?
It it, it's kinda like when a, when a woman goes to her dog
and asks the dog who ate the lipstick
and the dog's just
like, I don't know what you're talking about.
I have no idea, right? Like, isn't
that the most absurd picture you've ever seen in your life?
Right? It's kind of fun.
Some weeks I get to search for stuff like that. It's wild.
But that's kinda what's happening here.
It's Saul is just like, I obeyed, did I not?
And Saul and Samuels, do you not hear this?
This is exactly what God told you not to do.
And so it seems like Saul is caught just like the dog.
Like just seems like Saul is caught red-handed.
But as we've seen him do so far already, he had an excuse
and his excuse that this is gonna be key
for the rest of our time today.
His excuse seemed like a godly one.
It seemed like he was wanting to do things right.
Look at verse 14 again, then I'm gonna read 15 verse 14.
Samuel said, what then is this bleeding
of the sheep in my ears?
And the lowing of the oxen that I hear, Saul said, they,
they would be, the people have brought them from the
Amalekites, for the people spared the best of the sheep
and of the oxen to sacrifice to the Lord your God.
And the rest we devoted to destruction.
Haven't we seen this before from Saul?
Often in Saul's life there was this veneer of religion
where, where, where he even seemed
to be doing things right,
but in his heart he was not following the Lord.
He was doing good actions, religious things,
but in his heart he wasn't.
It's even look at verse 15.
There's a subtle shift when Saul says this to Samuel.
He says, they were sacrifices to the Lord your God.
You see that Saul, the king of Israel,
says to Samuel, Hey, we were gonna sacrifice to your God,
not my God, not our God, your God.
Again, further evidence
that Saul's heart was not toward the Lord at all.
But you have to think about it here.
Wouldn't wouldn't God want the best
of the best animals?
His offerings? It, it sure seems like
that's God, God's desire.
That's what he would want. I mean, why not?
He's, he says everywhere. Bring your best.
We say it here, right? Bring your best to the Lord.
Wouldn't God want this?
Except for the fact that God commanded them
to destroy it all?
It didn't matter how great those sacrifices were.
It was not what God wanted.
And watch how Samuel confronted Saul over his sin.
Verse 16, then Samuel
said to Saul, stop.
I will tell you what the Lord said to me this night.
And Saul said, speak. Look at verse 17 and on.
And Samuel said, though you are little in your own eyes,
are you not the head of the tribes of Israel?
The Lord anointed you king over Israel.
And the Lord sent you on a mission
and said, go devote to destruction the sinners,
the Amalekites fight against them until they're consumed.
Why then did you not obey the voice of the Lord?
Why did you pounce on the spoil
and do what was evil in the side of the Lord?
And Saul said to Samuel, I've obeyed the voice of the Lord.
I've gone on the mission in which the Lord sent me.
I brought a gag, the king of Amalek,
and I've devoted the Amalekites to destruction.
But the people took the spoil sheep
and oxen, the best of the things devoted to destruction,
to sacrifice to the Lord your God, in Gilgal.
So notice what Samuel was even doing for Saul in the moment.
Saul was, was bringing excuse after excuse.
And Samuel comes to him
and says, Hey listen, I'm gonna give you a way outta this.
I'm gonna give you a chance to repent
and to fix your mistake
that you could actually make this right.
But what does Saul do? He again shifts the blame.
It was the people who took all those animals.
Sam, come on Samuel, the people, I couldn't stop 'em.
The people took the animals they wanted
to sacrifice to your God.
Samuel, come on, give 'em a break.
How tragic though, right?
Deflecting, pointing fingers,
trying to excuse your behavior.
Grateful that we've moved past that in our day, haven't we?
No. Right? We all do this daily.
We all do this.
But the truth of the matter here is that excuses never work.
Never excuses
never work.
'cause here's what Saul had done.
Saul had listened to the wrong voice.
Whose voice did he listen?
He listened to the people's voice.
He listened to his own selfish voice.
He listened to every other voice
except the voice of the Lord.
He even said that he did it, but did he? No.
He partially might have done it,
but he didn't listen to the Lord
and say, I'm going to follow you in every way,
which compromised his obedience to God.
He listened to the wrong voice.
And so Samuel responds, really, this is the,
the next couple verses is the key section we've been
building to for the last five chapters.
All these weeks we've been looking at this narrative build
and build and build to culminate here in verses 22 and 23.
Watch what Samuel says to Saul
and Samuel said, has the Lord
as great delight in burnt offerings
and sacrifices as in obeying the voice of the Lord.
Behold, to obey is better than sacrifice.
And to listen than the fat of rams for rebellion is
as the sin of divination, witchcraft, presumption is
as iniquity and idolatry
because you have rejected the word of the Lord.
He has also rejected you from being king.
Just powerful. And
I wanna work backwards on that, those two verses.
Let's work up from the end to the beginning of
what Samuel said to Saul here, this is really critical.
Watch this. Saul had rejected God's word,
so God rejected him from being the king.
But it wasn't just that Saul had failed one time.
It wasn't that he just, he kind of made a mistake
and he failed one time.
It's that his heart was not oriented towards the Lord.
He didn't want to obey, he didn't want to listen to God.
He didn't wanna seek God. He wanted to try to pacify God.
Which then you move up verse 23, it says that
that's basically the same thing as witchcraft.
Rebellion is like witchcraft.
It's like idolatry.
When you presume upon yourself it's as bad as idolatry.
Do you see what he's doing here?
What he's saying is that all of it, every single sin,
no matter what class we might put it in, every one
of it separates you from God.
It's not that you have to be perfect to earn salvation,
because every one of us idolize, every one of us,
presume every one of us rebel.
We all do it.
What he's talking about here is it gets to your heart.
Even David will see him in a couple weeks show up.
He doesn't live this out perfectly,
but his heart was towards God, a man after God's own heart.
It's about the heart.
Just because someone on the outside like Saul looks
religious, if their heart is not toward
the Lord, all those actions are useless.
And what this says, what Samuel says, is that they are just
as guilty as an idol worshiper, as someone
who worships a false God, as an adulterer, as someone
who makes a deal with the devil.
It doesn't matter. You might be religious on the outside,
but if your heart is not towards God, it's the same
as adultery
because what does God really want?
You keep moving up that section, right?
What does God really want? Verse 23
for rebellion is the sin is divination.
Presumption is the sin of iniquity and idolatry.
What he said prior to that, behold
to obey is better than sacrifice
to listen than the heart, uh, the
to listen than the fat of rams.
Like you can offer all these sacrifices.
God wants you to listen to him. God wants you to obey him.
That's way better. God cares about sacrifices.
The entire book of Leviticus is about sacrifices.
God cares about how they're done well in the Old Testament.
But what does he want more? He wants the worshiper heart.
He wants the heart. He wants your heart.
He wants my heart. He wants every worshiper hearts.
What what that means is that he wants that person to listen
to his word, want to and want to obey.
That's what he wants. He doesn't even
want the best animal sacrificed to him
because that person, listen, this,
this is what we can get to.
This is the temptation of religious people like us.
This is where we can get. He doesn't even want that
sacrifice best, the best offering given.
He doesn't even want that when someone is using it
to cover up the rest of
what they're doing with the rest of their life.
You ever done that before? You've gone to church,
you've posted scripture on your social
media like you're supposed to.
You're, you've given money,
you've even served in the church,
yet the rest of your life
looks completely contrary to the way of Jesus.
Jesus very clearly said it, quoting Isaiah in Mark seven,
six, Jesus said this, people honors me with their lips,
but their heart is far from me.
I've, I've been there man, like
I've been there where everything else looks far from God.
But I've gotta put that front, that facade.
I've gotta make it look right. Can I tell you something?
It is miserable. It, it is.
I useless in the end.
What's, what's the benefit of it?
It's that people appreciate or respect you in some way.
You get what you want. It's useless in the end.
What does God want more than religious actions?
More than offerings, more than sacrifices.
What does God actually want the most? He wants your heart.
He says, to obey is better than sacrifice.
To obey is better than singing songs.
To obey is better than given.
Money to obey is better than sir like, to obey is
what God wants.
But what that means is there must be a fundamental change in
your desires that you actually want to obey him.
And that desire to obey him only comes from the orientation
of your life being toward him, right?
You see that you're not gonna wanna obey him if you don't
even want to follow him.
And so when you have that desire to follow him, then
as your king, he is someone you want to listen to.
You wanna say, okay, God, what do you want? Say to me?
What do you want to lead me into?
Because I want to obey what you want me to obey.
I wanna listen to you. My heart is oriented towards you.
I want you See how this all works?
There's gotta be a fundamental change inside
because I can only sustain those actions of religiosity,
of churchianity.
I can only do that for so long. I'm gonna fail at that.
I can't sustain it because it doesn't come from inside me.
But when my heart is changed by the spirit of God,
then my heart then wants to follow him.
It wants to go clean my room when he tells me to do it
and I'll do it joyfully.
None of that was true of Saul, right? That that was not he.
He was more focused on making sure everybody else was happy.
He wanted to make sure everybody else had what they wanted.
He wanted to make sure that he looked good.
He even built a memorial to himself in response
to this victory over the Amalekites.
He wanted to make sure he looked good, that he had a veneer
of religion that might appease God.
Like that's what he was trying.
He was all focused on himself. It didn't work.
God saw right through it.
He knew Saul's heart. He rejected him.
Well, you can imagine that. Finally hit Saul.
All this has happened. Saul finally
recognizes what has happened.
Everything we've been building to it's now final
that Saul had officially been
rejected as the king of Israel.
He stays in the position for a few more chapters,
we'll see going forward.
But he's rejected as king of Israel. He will not sustain it.
God is going to replace him.
And watch how Saul tried to respond and just feel this.
Maybe this is something you felt in your life.
Verse 24, Saul said to Samuel,
I have sinned for I have transgressed the commandment
of the Lord and your words because I feared the people
and obeyed their voice.
Now therefore, please pardon my sin
and return with me that I may bow before the Lord.
And Samuel said to Saul, I will not return with you.
You have rejected the word of the Lord.
The Lord has rejected you from being king over Israel.
As Samuel turned to go away, Saul sees the skirt
of his robe and it tore.
And Samuel said to him, the Lord has torn the kingdom
of Israel from you this day
and has given it to a neighbor
of yours who's better than you.
And also the glory of Israel will not lie
or have regret, for he is not a man
that he should have regret.
And then Saul said, I've sinned yet honor me now
before the elders of my people and before Israel
and return with me that I may bow before the Lord your God.
So Samuel turned back after Saul and Saul bowed
before the Lord.
Now we read that and we wonder,
had Saul changed it, it sure seemed like now I've sinned.
I've done everything wrong. Had Saul changed?
It seems like he's repentant.
But again, did you see his perspective in verse 30?
I emphasized it right.
He still wanted to be honored
before the Lord, before his people.
He was still focused on himself.
He's like, Samuel, please, I don't wanna look
bad in front of my people.
So Samuel, can you come with me and and let me bow down
before you and it looks like I'm doing the right thing.
That's kind of what he's saying, right?
Again, he could have owned up.
He could have said, I'm guilty.
He could have said, I am wrong. I failed.
I could even go make it right, right.
Now, imagine if he goes and he takes care of the king
and he goes and takes care of all the sheep.
He could have made it right at the time. But Saul never did.
Saul never did. And it sets us up this tension between Saul
and whoever this new king will be in the upcoming chapters.
This neighbor, who Samuel says, is better than you,
not better morally, better focused on the Lord
as a king should be in Israel.
And there will be a tension that we'll see play out over the
next few chapters.
But watch the sad conclusion here, Samuel
and Saul, part ways never to speak again.
Verse 34, Samuel went to Rama and Saul went up to his house
and Gibbon and Samuel did not see Saul again
until the day of his death.
But Samuel grieved over Saul
and the Lord regretted
that he had made Saul King over Israel.
What a tragedy, isn't it?
This whole chapter, man like Saul, this man
with such great potential anointed
as God's first king of Israel,
yet a man whose heart wasn't in it.
His heart was not devoted to the Lord.
And that caused God much grief,
knowing what he had to do to replace Saul with a new king
that was a man after God's own heart.
But but that's the idea.
That word regret, God doesn't change.
God doesn't need new information.
It's the idea of what it does to his heart that that that's
what sin does.
It brings sorrow, great sorrow
to God's heart.
But how do we reconcile this? It seems like God regrets.
It says it. But what we learn here is
that somehow in his sovereignty, God chooses
to respond to human actions.
But his purposes and plans never change God's way above us.
He, we can't understand this, but that's how he's set it up.
That he somehow responds to disobedience when it comes
and responds to obedience when it comes to us,
it seems like, but,
but that's the way God has set it up to work out.
Because you remember this, one of the key stipulations
for the King of Israel was that they were
to be wholeheartedly devoted to God
and obeying his commands.
If they failed at that, remember they were to repent.
They were to turn back to him.
If they didn't return, if their heart was not
oriented toward him, then God says, I will reject you.
So is God dependent on us?
No, that's the way God set it up to work.
And so he would reject a king who wasn't focused.
That's why God had said to Saul, I'm gonna replace you
with a man after your after God's own heart.
That's the key. Remember the heart is the issue.
But he said to the king, you must obey me.
But listen, don't we have the same key stipulation
for us today, like
as his representatives on earth,
which the king was his representative in Israel
as his representatives on earth.
Now, aren't we supposed to be wholeheartedly devoted
to listening to His word and obeying his word?
And when we fail, what do we do?
We turn back to him in repentance.
That's what we're called to do.
But here is a key difference that king
failed, rejected the key difference for us.
If we are his by faith,
he will never reject us.
Now what's the difference?
Shouldn't we as Christians get rejected just like
that king get rejected?
Shouldn't that be the case? Why is it different now?
Because we have a substitute who perfectly
obeyed all of God's commands
and then who also died as our substitute so we wouldn't have
to die because of our failures.
See, that's the truth that changes everything is
that Christ obeyed perfectly.
The king was supposed to obey. He failed our king.
Check this out, right? Our king who now reigns overall,
he did obey perfectly.
And so he has the right to stand
as the permanent king forever.
'cause here's what Hebrews four 15 says,
that we do not have a high priest who is unable
to sympathize with our weaknesses.
We have a high priest who in every respect has been tempted
as we are yet without sin.
There's a lot of research going on in our world that
asks people who call themselves Christians,
theological questions.
One of those questions that's often asked is, did Jesus sin?
There is a shockingly high amount of people
who call themselves Christians and say,
yeah, Jesus sin just like me.
He's a man. That's a problem
because then we don't have a standard
or we don't have a, a substitute in our place taking on the
sin that we did on a perfect sacrifice.
And so we don't have that first of all.
But then the flip side is called the double
double imputation.
We also then don't have any righteousness planted on us
because of his perfection.
That's why Jesus being perfect is so critical for us
because he said He is perfect.
He lived it out. He is perfect.
And so he takes our sin as our substitute.
And then he gives us his righteousness as our substitute
because he perfectly obeyed.
That is a key part of the gospel.
You cannot be a Christian
if you don't have that covering you.
You might be religious, but it's not a heart change.
And so I want to, I wanna just say something
because I know this is where I've been.
When we hear sermons
or Bible studies about obedience,
we all sit in this feeling of like,
man, I failed this morning.
God's telling me I'm supposed to obey. He wants my heart.
My heart was not oriented to him even an hour ago, right?
Like, and we're sitting here,
we get discouraged, get overwhelmed.
We get sad. We get beaten up
by a pastor just says, you need to obey, right?
We're supposed to listen and obey, trust and obey.
There's no other way to be happy in Jesus
and trust and obey, right?
Like that's, that's what we hear.
But we sit here and we think I, I can't.
I struggle with that. I'm not perfect at it.
And so I just wanna blow this down for a second.
I want us to sit here in this
Christian, listen, God never
regrets saving you.
He says He regretted making Saul King.
It's 'cause he was so grieved over the sin.
Christian God never regrets saving you
even when you don't go clean your room.
He knew what he was buying.
He knew what he was getting into.
He knew what you would be like when he was purchasing
you on the cross.
Now, he wants you to listen to nor obey, not just
because He wants you to 'cause it's good for us.
It's better. Our life is better in a sense
whenever we do listen and obey.
But he also knows that he doesn't want
religious rituals with no heart.
He doesn't want that. He wants
you to listen and obey,
but he doesn't want it done with no heart.
But when you fail, if your heart is toward it,
when you fail, and you will, the truth
of the gospel is that you have an advocate.
You have someone who stands in your place in death
and stands in your place in life
and he never regrets saving you.
What? Great love is this right church. That kind of love.
That's what makes me want to listen to him.
That kind of love is what makes me want to hear his commands
that are good for me as he leads me in grace.
It's that kind of love that's so great.
That makes me want to obey him in every way.
Not because I have to, but
because I've been given the grace to do it.
So let's reflect on that as I pray for a moment here.
Reflect on that great love of God.
We're gonna take the Lord's supper here in a moment
to remind us of the broken body and shed blood of Jesus.
But, but Jesus, remember, Jesus did that
because he loves you.
Christian. Rest in that.
Let that spur and compel us towards obedience and action.
When we hypocritically live a life
that we're not living on the inside, let's just stop,
confess it, own up
and say, Jesus, I wanna follow you in his grace.
He'll meet you in it.